uh it's uh my pleasure to be here and
sorry for the delay my name is Jose
mourtazavi I'm a data scientist based in
Estonia uh this is my LinkedIn you can
connect with me it will be it would be
my pleasure to be connected so watch me
uh
I got my master uh in industrial
engineering I was lucky during Master
studies I found that I I really like
working with
data and it's it's my passion then I I
was working with my teacher in a uh in a
oil and gas company in Iran in my
country and then moved to another
another company his name is it's as a
sales data analyst and finally I moved
to a snap snap is a
unicorn company in Iran uh thanks
student I learned lots of things from
them and then
during the pandemic I move I relocate to
uh to Estonia in another company as a
marketing data analyst and then switched
to data scientists yeah that was a you
know brief history of uh my uh last six
or seven years of my career
and my expertise is uh using recommender
system in Industry uh so since it's
beyond the scope of this tutorial uh I
will I would like you know to talk if
you have a question regarding
recommender system how to develop in the
product uh we we can you know talk after
that
uh and
so for today we have two part of uh
uh presentation
for this tutorial the first part is just
the warm-up how to uh write simple
simple codes uh in pandas before that
how many of you guys are familiar with
pandas
okay okay we have a good bunch of you
guys that uh no pandas
and since lots of you your these users
this uh these the people here uh know
pandas very well but some of them maybe
they are new so I I will try to in the
middle and you know write some codes and
please uh Follow Me by this uh the links
that I will share with you and you will
uh have access to the exact file that I
am working and you can make a copy on
your on your drive and run run the codes
so and then the next part that is the
amazing and the main part is how to use
chaining chaining technique and also
assign and the combination of chaining
assign and also long does inside Panda
Security to have more uh readable and
more productive to be more productive in
in when you write codes in pandas and
then I will talk about some writing
queries inside pandas and joins and and
and if if you have a find a time so we
can talk about other methods that are
usually used in my day-to-day and then
and if you have a question uh I will
answer uh and during the uh since I'm
writing codes uh in live and uh please
interrupt me if you would if you would
like to uh
if you have a question or maybe have a
problem during writing your code so
um
uh what is pandas
pandas is a python package that for
using for data analysis it's like Excel
but what you do in Excel mostly using
you know a kind of we have rows and also
columns so uh the concept behind Excel
and Ponders I we should say they are the
same and if you know Excel it's I think
it helps and I believe that it's helped
you to understand uh upon those uh
better so pandas is easy is easy to
learn easy to use to uh to use and it's
fast it's powerful and you you can more
than one billion or rows you can analyze
data on it it's so fast and it's open
source it means that you don't need to
purchase an account or maybe pay for it
it's supported by lots of developers and
around 3K of the developer at the moment
they are
working on uh pandas so um
uh two building blocks of pandas are
series and data frame series are just
indexes plus one one column and they
store frame are two-dimensional a label
data set it means like Excel that we
have we have here we have rows and also
columns it's exactly uh we we can say
it's uh it's uh
data frame so let's import and you know
build your hands with some some code so
I just import uh pandas
and also
but they are the same
uh oh yeah yeah exactly this is a string
here right
[Music]
yeah for it for every day it's uh return
the number of registration and also the
demand and we have also calendar okay
calendar data set that's uh uh we can
use
exactly this one and
read data sets and also
okay
uh
sure
yes for every uh it's a contained and
for every day is is it working day or
isn't it not and weather is like exactly
like this so let's
uh copy and paste for the sake of time
so and let's check it and we just want
to whether
data set
and it's contained it's a I think it's a
good uh you know for data analysis it's
a good data set so I I use it so I just
want to uh
create a new column and what is the
trend of buy X demand over the time so
we we want to you know join this data
set merge okay we again we use uh use
chaining inside inside pandas so we use
merge with another another data set to
uh to to merge them basically merge
join data sets on
it's like
joining in in SQL that that I mentioned
here left to and right chain you can uh
you know do do it on uh and uh bit uh
you know Common column the common column
is this one and you can also use uh and
join another one it's here and it's for
and use weather weather okay
and then check the result
sorry there is typo
here
yes this is you know the bank the bike
data sets and it's uh it's uh the merge
as you see it's just as uh as let's
check the the real uh the real bike data
set okay
it's
it's just this one but we just we with
this you know with this chaining we just
on the Fly we just create you know merge
merge them and let's answer the but
before answer the question we just
assign and create a new column and use
this one equal uh again Lambda and
input feed it to the x uh
let's con just I want to convert to uh
this one the to the uh to the date
daytime
encounters to you know to have some
functionality
to date time yes and it's uh
that uh this yes
but there is a problem with this since
it's a start as you see here it's a
start with the day and we just you know
we should mention and format it here
let's just quick format on this uh we
just need a percentage percentage D
percentage
percentage month and uh another
percentage here okay and as you see
there is there is an another column and
let's check the the type of it with dot
d types
yes as you can see it's a function here
so we you can
for example convert it to and answer the
first question and for each year
we can see uh
uh with date it's we have a new new
column its name is date with this one
you can it's uh you know the time series
functionality in pandas that for example
with this one you can use date dot
detail for simplest for you know pretty
more readability I just use this one
that year
you need uh dot DT and Dot here okay
here okay
and just value cons
uh no no no sorry it's sir
but uh I what is the trend of the so
basically we just let's you know answer
this one and it's another uh but the
answer is not uh not exactly this one
but just the value counts just the value
counts
[Music]
um
okay there is a type also here
so it's it should be contained two years
for every day it's uh here but but this
is not the exact uh the exact answer for
this one it's just for each year uh we
need
group
Group by
okay
five minutes okay so uh
uh yeah it's I think for this five
minute if you have a question I will
answer it and I will hear uh if you
would like we can I can you know answer
your question and sorry again for you
know uh disruption I couldn't you know I
usually you know use vs code and with my
laptop it's you know I would be you know
more productive but there are some you
know uh issue technical issue sorry
again okay
do you find the chaining is a you know
is bigger or maybe it's my you know my
uh you know after I uh use this
technique my productivity for you know
for writing code is increasing
especially when I you know deliver my
code to other and share my code with
others they understand what's happening
inside even those people that they are
they are just you know business people
maybe it's my manager I just I mean when
I talk with them it's okay uh you know
they they don't understand every of
piece of those code but when it's you
know it's a kind of you know flow or
maybe a pipeline of of functions and
methods uh it's easier for them to
understand or maybe uh for even for
myself you know you know back to my code
uh for a few uh maybe a few days or
maybe a few weeks it would be you know
much easier
so
yes
and there are uh and there are other
useful uh
uh message in uh in pandas did use one
of these uh in your uh you know analysis
before
which one is your favorite one
which one
apply oh yeah employees yeah yes
what would map
uh
is in I I put it here isn't its uh like
you know uh
you can create a list uh and I think I
have it some sample here but it's you
know since it's a it's a bit you know
different uh uh names it's got error but
no worries you know they find the the
things for example I just uh the ease in
for example if you want to just select
this month's January February March it's
easier you know to to do this you know
instead of uh you know use this one unit
I always you know for debugging uh then
you know always I recommend to use you
know unich uh or maybe test your codes
since you know you write something but
you don't know for example as as I show
here in in above uh it's uh
you write something and the output you
since there are lots of rows you don't
you don't know is it you know correct or
not you know unique is the best one for
example you can filter and understand
which of those value counts as our
friends mentioned
and also feeling a what's uh
what
which method you use you usually use for
filling a
no approach yeah
yeah how to decide for example
in your yeah
okay
foreign
for each category you get me the number
of really expression for today to get
the right answer
yeah
there are even some you know complex so
for example they usually use some you
know maybe regression to understand
which one of these numbers is the best
yeah but they are they are complex
approach I usually use you know simple
foreign
yeah yeah
uh
yeah
NPR is is easy easy that you know if you
I I just want to uh say it in a quick
answer it's easy it's easy to understand
but there are other other things like
you know uh like writing a function for
example if if equal this and user apply
but you should use or maybe Lambda but
they are uh it's
for Simplicity is better
and
yeah it's
um
yeah that's all from and uh you have uh
you know we have these files and also in
my GitHub uh you can uh it should be
here uh in this uh yes this is the
repository that you can see the data
sets and also you can download them and
use these files to uh to read uh to you
know rerun again and if you you know
find it if you have a question I can
answer them and okay
or
years into learning data science
they would like to collaborate projects
uh so uh
you want to have a come to to suggest
some teams for the people that want to
join as a data analyst or data scientist
okay
okay
yeah yeah yeah uh for example the the
first years that you know I start
learning uh Python and uh especially
upon us
uh it's back sheets around uh six or
seven years ago uh it's uh you know
communicate with other people you know
in kagger kaggle is the best the best
place you know read uh read other people
quotes Bill gets even you know have a
have a kind of you know suggestion to
you know read other super code
especially in uh in in kaggle you know
let's jump to the Kegel if you have it
uh
side by side yeah yeah yeah and you know
yeah exactly you know communicates and
you know collaboration with other people
in in her
it's neat I think here but maybe like
you know some some data sets uh
it should be here data sets yes and in
this for example for this one
in this uh discussions and quotes
you can see the you know the other
people code and you can learn what what
they they want to do and what what they
usually do it is the best way you can
also create uh you know group of uh or
teamwork with with other people I
usually use you know this and I'm
connected with some uh some people in
kaggle and I I usually use kagger yeah
it's the best one the best approach
okay thank you thank you